Woke up to absolute breaking news
to the Bridget mother time travel theory community.
She's now a space CEO.
She started a space communications company. You guys,
this is the Bridget Mother time travel theory part four.
We're going to space, baby!
If you're new here,
I firmly believe that Bridget Mother is the first
confirmed time traveler.
And for a long time,
my main evidence has been in her Twitter bio,
where she listed time travel question Mark.
But I've been missing this whole time, a key,
important moment.
Space enthusiast
listed in her Twitter bio,
which has now changed.
Her Twitter bio is completely different now.
She's a new like,
CEO profile pic
and her bio just says
CEO and cofounder of Northwood Space.
Now, what is this new company?
Northwood Space.
It's a space communications company.
So basically,
it's making it easier to get the information from space
down to earth
for people who might not be giant mega corporations
that have access to all the things you need to do that.
Now, the vision is
a data highway between earth and space.
This is important here.
Space is getting easier
along so many different dimensions,
including the dimension of time.
I've always said that Bridget mother first built
her time machine during the pandemic,
and this article all but confirms that.
Well, everybody else was making their sourdough starters
during the 2020 pandemic.
We were building antennas
out of random crap we could find at Home Depot.
And receiving data from satellites.
Who's to say she wasn't also building a time machine
at that time?
She tweeted today
expect the unexpected.
So excited to announce our 6.3 million dollar seed.
Maybe Bridget builds the time machine
along with her two super genius engineer co founders.
These 3 will build a time machine.
Or should I say
they already have.
All this is to say,
if we look at what our Twitter bio had.
Actress? Check.
Musician? Check.
MIT PMSP, she's getting it.
Harvard Lottery,
she's getting it.
Space enthusiast.
She's starting a space company.
Time travels.
The only thing left.
And don't even get me started
in the way that this new company
connects back to her role in the click,
because that's a whole other video.